this is the rally's palm pit viper and
it's as dangerous as it is rare
there are 10 species of palm pit viper
that inhabit the cloud forests of
central america
but of all of them the rallies is the
most rare and elusive
it can only be found on three isolated
mountains in southern mexico
brilliant green and slender these vipers
will spend most of their lives coiled
quietly in trees and other vegetation
they are not aggressive by nature but
will strike if disturbed
a bite from a rallies is not likely to
be fatal to humans but be warned
no specific anti-venom exists for this
extraordinary species of snake
while not necessarily a threat to us
those that should be worried are the
small mammals and tree frogs that the
viper preys upon
those that stray too close will meet a
swift and silent end
but even these venomous predators can't
stave off bigger threats
deforestation and over collection for
the pet trade are perilous threats for
this rare animal
this is the rally's palm pit viper